this is my last video of the year and I
just finished watching making a murderer
all 10 episodes I am feeling everything
that's afoot hey guys welcome to this
video I thought since the holidays of
Christmas gift-giving etc just happened
I would show you what I got for
Christmas because sharing is what the
internet is all about and so is
narcissism so this does both of those
things called shaking efficient of me
god I love myself you don't want to max
out on my narcissism before we get to
the end amateur move what do i absolute
favorite gifts that I got this year for
Christmas is this shirt yeah who says I
love John Hill bag and this is John
Helbig and John how big is my older
brother he is not a member of the duck
dynasty is not a pirate or a
professional wrestler doesn't race
monster truck or Gators in skates no
he's just a man years and years ago my
brother made gifts for our entire family
there were red t-shirts that say I heart
John Helbig on them and I've worn them
in videos before and it was one of my
favorite gifts of all time I thought it
was so funny
now maybe ten years later he made this
shirt just for me he's upgraded his
photoshopping which I truly appreciate
so god bless my brother is an artist I
love this shirt thank you John uh what
else did I get can you see it no that's
not this kind of video say salt crystal
lamp this is a lamp made of one giant
block of Himalayan sea salt is it
emmeline Cecil uh dough mind and chip by
hand in the Himalayan mountains this
lamp is just one big hunk of Himalayan
salt and the best part is my younger
brother Tim got my mom a big giant one
of these and she opened hers first and
then revealed that she got both myself
and Tim one of these all three of us
have Himalayan salt crystal lamps
they're supposed to purify your air and
ionize your body in some way they're
supposed to make you a better person I'm
having a
laughs that looks like a scrotum with an
unknown disease doesn't make me a better
person I don't know what will
it's so it sometimes you wake up and you
just want to feel like a horse with a
salt leg thank you mom for making my
dreams a reality
what else did I get this is also a gift
from my older brother it is a paparazzi
play set these are dolls that are
supposed to be paparazzi why they make
this toy I don't know but my brother
bought it caution
small parts not suitable for children
under 36 months also probably not
suitable for like a dog or humans or
animals plants none of my objects cute
what happen again this year I got my
mother some adult coloring books because
they're supposed to be cool and relaxing
and they're very now and then my mother
got me an adult coloring book discover
your inner creative side Wow my cousin
got me why my coffee if you don't know
what awawa is a wah wah is everything
what was the convenience store that is
specific to this area of the United
States I think it's in some areas in
Pennsylvania and Delaware and southern
New Jersey and it's just a wonderful
convenience store that just truly
Trump's every other convenience store
and also Donald Trump probably like be a
much better presidential candidate than
Donald Trump himself it's got a
touchscreen system for ordering hoagies
that'll solve a lot of America's
problems my dad and my stepmom gave me
this a tank top of New Jersey that says
home my house in Los Angeles was quickly
becoming a temple to New Jersey I now
have a New Jersey ship cutting board a
necklace of New Jersey a print of New
Jersey a no tank top with New Jersey on
it we hate to forget where we're from us
Jersey folk what else this is really fun
my younger brother Tim who if you guys
aren't following him on Twitter
he's just goddamn hilarious you got me
this card
has Santa on the front hairy holiday
specific for him and the inside says
believe in the magic of Christmas dear
grace I tried to get you a gift but I
just don't even know anymore love Tim my
brother got me the gift of honesty this
year and I hate it I can't return it to
Target thank you Tim I then the last
thing I will show you is maybe one of
the greatest gifts my mother has ever
given me I gave my family members
portraits of me in this photo I wanted
them to have an updated photo of me
because that's my charity work for the
year and then my mom not knowing that
she was getting that portrait for me
gave me these Porter's there my mother
is an assistant teacher in a
special-needs classroom so every year
the teachers get photos just like the
students and she got an excess of photos
of herself
and she didn't want this many photos of
herself so she gifted them to me I mean
who needs any sort of DNA testing it's
very clear this holiday season that I am
this woman's child thank you mom
so that's it for this holiday haul I
hope you guys enjoyed it and that's it
for this year 2015 Wow let's look back
on some of our greatest moments this
year incredible thank you very much for
being so supportive continuously I'm
really excited for 2016 I I genuinely
think it's going to be a very good year
2016 and I really hope that you guys
feel the same way because let's do cool
have a wonderful safe lovely memorable
maybe boring in the best way possible
new year's see you in 2016 I don't know
and it's very heavy very dense like my
brain wow look at that it's the size of
my head and face which one is more
unnecessary